[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
on the heels of this historic peace deal
between the united
emirates and israel the trump
administration has been working overtime
to protect american interest in the
middle east and around the world
in asia secretary of state mike pompeo
is cracking down on the communist party
of china
starting with placing restrictions on
diplomats here
on u.s soil pompeo's goal is to level
the playing field
and respond to the restraints china
already has in place
on americans this comes as tensions with
china seem to be reaching
a fever pitch yesterday the pentagon
reported china's plans to double
their nuclear stockpile in the next 10
years and today
during an interview attorney general
bill barr
issued this warning listen of those
three countries that the intelligence
community has pointed to
russia china and iran which is the most
assertive the most aggressive in this
area
i believe it's china which one china
china more than russia right now yes why
do you say that because i've seen the
intelligence that's what i've concluded
joining us now with more is united
states secretary of state mike pompeo mr
secretary thank you for joining us
congressman gary it's great to be with
you likewise
tell us about the actions you've taken
against china with respect to their
diplomats and why you took it
well trade today we took the simple
action of telling chinese diplomats
working here in the united states that
the free ride is over their ability to
conduct espionage here in the united
states
has time has passed and so we've put
restrictions on the money to ask
permission now to
conduct meetings with local officials
and to gather at certain levels
these are the kind of restrictions we've
had on us our diplomats in china and now
we've got a reciprocal arrangement
it's the same thing president trump has
done in every dimension
for 40 years trey the united states took
any it bent a knee
to the chinese communist party and
president trump has said enough whether
it's on trade
or on their stealing of intellectual
property and trade secrets destroying
jobs here in the united states
we're simply not going to take it
anymore we're going to demand that the
chinese communist party
that authoritarian regime not treat
america in the way that it has for all
these decades
well mr secretary before you were the
secretary of state you were the head of
the cia and you were also
on the house intelligence committee when
you served in the house do you
view china as our country's greatest
threat is it on par with with russia or
ahead of russia
trade the the singular greatest threat
to the united states of america from
foreign power emanates from the chinese
communist party it's
not frankly a close call i heard the
attorney general's comments today about
the particular threat related to
elections but broader and more deeply
than that the chinese communist party is
building out its military
it has infiltrated the united states in
ways that russia has not
and its economic might has been used
through state-owned enterprises and
subsidizing companies to destroy
tens of thousands of jobs all across the
heartland in america
it's unacceptable behavior and president
trump's not going to permit it to
continue
and then of course we're all suffering
even today from the wuhan virus the
chinese communist party had a chance
to slow it down to stop it to let the
world know what was taking place
and instead of giving us full disclosure
they covered up
this is thousands of lives and billions
of dollars in wealth destroyed in the
united states and all across the world
this is what authoritarian regimes do
it's what president trump is working to
make sure
they can never do again to america
mr secretary you mentioned china as a
military threat what are they doing to
increase their military capacity
and what should americans know about
that and be concerned about
well they've increased their budget
significantly it's permitted them to
conduct an enormous amount of missile
tests increasing risk throughout
southeast asia
they're building out their navy they're
professionalizing their military
truly building up a capacity not just to
be effective in their coastal waters but
to create power that can reach
all across the globe and then they're
co-opting other countries they're using
their military power
building bases around the world as well
this has been going on for far too long
we're going to turn the tide the world
has begun to see this is trey this is
about the
central ideas of freedom versus
authoritarianism
america knows how to win these
confrontations and with president
trump's leadership
i'm very confident that we will we've
spent more money on our military over
the last two years than
any year in the previous decade you and
i served in congress together
we saw the struggle we had to do that
president trump is letting
he's going to build out our military
he's going to take care of our soldiers
our sailors our airmen and marines
we'll be ready mike
you recently took some action with
respect to the icc the international
criminal court why did you take that
action and why was that in america's
best interest
you know trey i think most americans
aren't familiar with the international
criminal court this is a
a group of political hacks in the hague
a place
that is threatening our kids who served
in afghanistan are
young men and women who served and
fought there this is a rogue court with
lawyers that are frankly corrupt and
political
and they are threatening to prosecute
americans who engaged in
america's fight for freedom in
afghanistan it's unacceptable and so we
have
begun to put real pressure on the court
to tell the court just the united states
didn't participate in the agreements
that set up this court
we want nothing to do with it and you're
darn sure you're not going to prosecute
americans
so we we today sanction a couple of the
people who are at the center
of the effort to prosecute americans and
we won't rest until it's the case that
we are confident that
no no mother no father has to worry that
their child traveling across the world
might be hauled in
by this court in the hague
mike there was a historic agreement
between the uae
and israel what should americans know
about that
and what's iran been doing since we have
not just heard as much about them as
russia and china lately
you know trey it was truly historic to
watch
and in fact listen to the conversation
between prime minister netanyahu and
the leader of the united united arab
emirates crown prince mohammed bin zayed
and president trump a historic peace
agreement where
we've had this long history of the arab
states not recognizing
uh israel as the jewish homeland and as
it's
as it ought to be a nation has a right
to exist president trump his vision for
peace is beginning to come to fruition
we've now seen
the first country in two and a half
decades recognize israel's right to
exist and you can already see
the benefits to both the people of
israel and the people of the united arab
emirates
the part came in about in part because
of the president's decision early on
he recognized that the islamic republic
of iran was the greatest threat to
stability in the middle east the
greatest rest to our kids our men and
women and our safety here in the united
states
the united arab emirates and israel both
recognize iran as this great threat
so they've now found a way to build out
a relationship which
can build out a coalition to ultimately
make sure that this threat never reaches
american shores
or harms anyone in the middle east
either
secretary secretary pompeo thank you for
your service to our country including
your service
in uniform when you finished at west
point